[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
l'exposition lemoine hors jeu est la
plus importante rétrospective consacrée
à ce jour à l'artiste québécois hors
norme qui est serge lemoine lemoine a
été d'un imaginaire très caractérisé par
sa série inspirée des glorieux les
canadiens dans les années 70
parmi les oeuvres marquantes de la
période bleue blanc rouge de lemoine
exposés on retrouve les emblématiques
dryden lafleur stardust et béliveau
pendant dix ans lemoine a été inspirée
du but de la rouge et à l'époque d'une
chose le bleu blanc rouge était au
maximum de sa gloire le canadien gagne à
chaque année la coupe stanley ou presque
près de 200 oeuvres et une centaine de
documents d'archivés illustrent les
différentes périodes d'une carrière
artistique qui s'étale sur 40 ans avec
toujours cette même quête de l'artiste
d'abolir les frontières entre l'art et
la vie c'est présent toute sa carrière
et c'est ce qui a fait qu'il a été un
petit peu rejetés par l'élite culturelle
parce que lui est considéré que l'art
comme le sport devrait dans notre vie de
tous les jours et c'est une vision qu'on
partage au musée c'est à dire que pas
besoin d'être de connaître là pour aimer
l'art c'est une expérience d'abord
humaine émotive
ici dans ce cas la joyeuse
l'exposition vise un public très large
les visiteurs pourront s'attarder devant
le maersk mythique de ken dryden en même
temps qu'ils découvriront un artiste
engagé on a choisi le titre serment hors
jeu et la définition de hors jeu c'est
se mettre dans une position interdite
par le jeu c'est une personne qui allait
qu'elle est au delà des conventions
esthétique au delà des conventions
muséal dans les années 60 notamment 1
un artiste iconoclaste qui travaillait
beaucoup avec les abonnés beaucoup avec
la participation du public c'est une
personne qui était très rassembleur
l'exposition lemoine hors jeu sera
présentée jusqu'au 9 janvier au musée
national des beaux arts du québec est
ici valérie cloutier radio canada québec